dangerous and deadly overcrowding on
Mount Everest is not likely to end
anytime soon the Paul says it has no
plans to limit permits on the world's
highest mountain at least 11 people 11
have died this season alone experienced
climbers complain about traffic jams
near an area with low oxygen levels they
call it the death zone that's pretty
direct this season's death toll is the
highest since Nepal since the 2015 Nepal
earthquake that triggered an avalanche
their high-altitude climbers Jim
Davidson survived that disaster it was a
huge battle ancho powder blasts we're
all out of attempt to see the Avalanche
Wow he reached the top of Mount Everest
two years later and Jim Davidson now
reaches the table of CTM congratulations
on that final journey we're glad to have
you thank you very much good you look
good thank you
very good very good a lot of crowding on
Everest more fatalities than people have
seen in many years what's going on there
it's been an especially bad year we've
had some bad weather and so the days
that people could go for the summit got
all compressed there was a bigger crowd
than average and maybe some people that
weren't fully trained you stack all
those together and it turned out to be a
really bad the changes to the permitting
process or other other regulations that
could fix this the government does issue
permits but there seems to be no limit
to the number of permits I'll issue they
keep adding more each year and so we're
seeing creeping but they no outing
I think they should restrict it some
especially based on experience it's hard
to set an exact number but if you keep
letting more people come it's gonna get
worse I'm surprised at the whole permit
situation because it's $11,000 to get
the permit and that's just a piece of
paper you were telling me correct I mean
there's much more cost in terms of
actually getting up there with equipment
and the time you have to invest correct
takes about two months the average cost
might be 45 thousand US dollars and it
takes a lot of your personal time to get
ready and stuff on the family too but
Jim some of the video we're looking at
you're literally waiting in line to die
because you must you must know that it's
not going well as you're standing there
waiting in line take us through that
process what is that feeling that people
just don't say look I'm out of here
well you we are up in the Death Zone
about 26,000 feet and that means even on
bottled oxygen you're slowly dying and
you can just feel it
right I can feel your energy draining
out of your legs and out of your core
and you got a disassociate in your mind
it gets very difficult to be up there
just to exist
what is people on that line dealing with
they're dealing with all that and the
anxiety of I know I'm going too slow and
I want to summit and what we call summit
fever which is this desire you're so
close and you want to summit and you're
pulled mentally with this strain of I
want to go up but I should go down even
though you know you could possibly die
you don't get out of the line is that
the is that the Credo with you guys well
not really I think if you're really
smart and have self-knowledge and a
guide and companions will look at each
other and say this is not our day we
need to go down but it takes great
strength and great self-knowledge to
make that very different I'm getting
down can be tricky you were saying
because you have to go past that line
you've got when we pass each other one
of us has to unclip from the line in
order to get by each other yes so you're
sort of kind of like shimmying by is
that trying to cooperate but you don't
speak the same language you're wearing a
mask it's difficult to talk so if
there's constant exposure to danger
young people climbing Everest they know
it's dangerous right they're paying a
lot of money to do it anyway is it
possible and some take away from this
that with 11 fatalities the allure of
Everest will actually increase and
overcrowding will actually become more
of a problem you would think that things
would be a little less next year - I
think you would hear the headline 11
people died last year you might rethink
your trips even get a refund on that 11
grand yeah you would think that but the
data actually shows that after a
disaster year the numbers go up the next
year Wow it has some sort of pull to
some magnetically to say people say I
want to go there I want experience it
and it is a gorgeous mountain and it's a
great experience to try and improve
yourself and be part of a great team
there's no qualification required for
getting the permit correct well the
guide company should do some screening
but maybe they don't do enough some of
the guide companies screens strictly and
some don't and that's the thing if
you're not ready yet you can find some
company that will take you up and I
think that needs to stop so how do you
fix it well I think it requires all of
us to take a portion of responsibility
climbers need to train harder and know
that it's helps better guides need to
say no to some people the government
needs to restrict the number of permits
um but you're talking about self
regulation it sounds like who's gonna
say I'm not qualified nobody I think
that above-average driver there yeah and
we need several layers we need the
guides to say no we need the government
one way they could do it is say you have
to climb other high
and if you haven't climbed those we
won't let you go on Everest now that'll
keep the business in Nepal spread the
climbers out and everyone will be more
ready when they get to mount it well
climb with Jim Davidson he's an
expedition leader he's been through it
all we appreciate you being here thank
you very much a pleasure thank you